Hmm,
what is that over there?
Eataly right now this is like a big.
What is it?
I don't know.
It's like a big one.
It's like a big Italian food mart where
they make all this stuff fresh.
The Pasta.
The bread.
The meat.
Well,
I don't make the meat fresh,
but they cut it.
You know what?
Let's go.
This Sandra.
Right.
Okay.
A lot of grief about those sneakers
today.
Not supposed to wear and he knew it was
black shoe.
Polish dollars for that.
Outrageous.
That's unbelievable.
Let's check it out.
The Macro Lens.
Let's see.
Look at that.
That's amazing.
What's going on this week?
Say,
what are we doing birthday?
How old is he?
So we ate what we ate.
That's what we just ate.
See,
I don't approve as you know,
because you follow my videos.
Rule number two,
instagram for me is don't take pictures
of food and yet every single person in
my family did that today.
How old are you turning this weekend?
Flavor,
flavor,
flavor.
Do you want sit macro lens,
salted Caramel,
salted caramel.
Hey,
I'm steven.
I'm here to talk about the
characteristics of hydrogen bonds.